let's say i've got some linear
transformation t
that is a mapping from rn
to
rn
so if this is its domain which is just
that is rn and then its codomain is also
rn
is also rn if you give me some vector in
our domain let's call that vector x then
t will map it
t will map it to some other member of
our of rn which is also the codomain so
it'll map it over here and we could call
that the mapping of t or the mapping of
x or t of x and since t is a linear
transformation we know that the mapping
of x to its codomain is equivalent to x
being multiplied
by some
matrix a so we know that this thing
right here is equal to some matrix a
times x you've seen all of this multiple
multiple times and just to make sure we
understand the wording properly we said
we've used the word that a
is the
we could either call it the matrix for t
or let's say it's the transformation
matrix
the transformation
mation
matrix
for
t
now in the last couple of videos we've
learned that the same vector can be
represented in different ways it can be
represented in different coordinate
systems and when i just write the vector
x like that we we just assume that it's
being represented in standard
coordinates or it's being represented
with respect to the standard basis so
let's be a little bit more particular a
this a is the transformation for t only
when x
only when x is represented in standard
coordinates or only when x is written in
coordinates with respect to the standard
basis so let me write a little qualifier
here a is the transformation for t a is
a transformation matrix for t
with
with respect
to
the standard basis
with respect to the standard basis i
never wrote this blue part before i
never even said this blue part before
because the only the only coordinate
system we were dealing with was the
standard coordinate system or the
coordinates with respect to the standard
basis but now we know that there are
multiple coordinate systems there are
multiple ways to represent this vector
there are multiple ways to represent
that vector because rn has multiple
spanning bases or there's multiple bases
that can represent rn and each of those
bases are essentially can generate a
coordinate system where you can
represent any vector in rn by some with
with with a coordinate with coordinates
with respect to any of those bases so
that that last part i said was a bit of
a mouthful so let me make it a little
bit more concrete
let's say that i have some basis b
that's made up of
n it has to be linearly independent
that's the definition of a basis of n
vectors v1
v2
all the way to
vn
now these are n linearly independent
vectors each of these are members of rn
so b
is
a basis
for
is a basis
is a basis for
rn which is just another way of saying
that all of these vectors are linearly
independent and any vector in rn can be
represented as a linear combination of
these guys which is another way of
saying that any vector in rn can be
represented with coordinates with
respect to this basis right there so the
same vector x i'm going to the same dot
here when we represent it in standard
coordinates we write it's just going to
be that right there that vector x but
what if we want to represent it in
coordinates with respect to this new
basis well then we could call that same
that same vector x will look like this
or we would give we would we would
denote it by this
the same vector can be represented with
respect to this basis so you know
this could be some set of coordinates
this would be some other set of
coordinates but it's still representing
the same basis
likewise
this vector right here that vector right
there is also an rn so it can be
represented by some linear combination
of these guys or you can represent it
with coordinates with respect to this
basis so that same point right there i
could represent it so that point is this
but i could represent it with
coordinates with respect to my basis
just like that
so this is an interesting question if or
this should maybe
bring an interesting question into your
brain
if i start off with something that's in
standard coordinates and i apply the
transformation t that's like applying
this matrix a to it or multiplying that
thing in standard coordinates times the
matrix a i then get the mapping of t in
standard coordinates now what if i start
off with that thing in non-standard
coordinates if i have a coordinates with
respect to this other basis here
well t should still map it to this guy
right t should be t should be it it
should t the transformation no matter
what should always map from that dot to
that dot it shouldn't care what your
coordinates are so t should still map so
let me draw another t should still map
to that same exact point
t should still be a linear
transformation and it could map from x
to t of x but that's the same thing as
mapping from this kind of way of
labeling x to this way of labeling x so
we could say
maybe
maybe t could be this transfer maybe
this guy right here could be some other
matrix times this guy over here so let
me write this over here
so
maybe t
i mean these are just different
coordinate systems so maybe i should i
shouldn't just even say maybe this guy
should be able to be represented
so if i represent the
the the mapping of x in our codomain
in coordinates with respect to b so
that's what that guy is right there so
if i want to map represent that dot with
this other coordinate system with
coordinates with respect to this basis i
want to represent it it should be equal
to the product of some other matrix let
me call that other matrix d
some other matrix d
times this representation of x
times
the rep the coordinates of x with
respect to my other my alternate
non-standard coordinate system i should
be able to find some matrix d that does
this and then we would call d
we would say that d
is
the
trans formation
matrix
for t
and a was with respect to a assumes that
you have x in terms in standard
coordinates but now d assumes that you
have x
in this other in in coordinates with
respect to this basis so with respect
with respect
to
the basis
the basis b
no reason why we shouldn't be able to do
this these things are just different
ways of representing the exact same
vector the exact same dot in our sets
here so if i represent it one way the
standard way i multiply it by a and i
get ax if i represent it in non-standard
coordinates i should be able to multiply
it by some other matrix and get another
non-standard coordinate representation
of what it gets mapped to so let's see
if we can find some relation between
d
between d
and between a
so we learned a couple of videos ago
that there's we can there's a there's a
change of basis matrix that we can
generate from this basis
and it's pretty easy to generate the
change of basis matrix is just a matrix
whose columns are these basis vectors
so v1
v2 and i shouldn't put a comma there
these are just the columns
v2
all the way to vn
this is an n by n matrix each of these
guys are members of rn and we have n of
them this is an n by n matrix and where
all of the columns are linearly
independent so we know that c is
invertible these are all column vectors
right here so we know that c is
invertible
and we learned in the last two or three
videos
that
that if we
have
some vector x if we have our vector x
and it's being represented by
coordinates with respect to our basis b
we can just multiply that by c
we can multiply that by c and we'll get
our vector x this is essentially will
tell us the linear combination of these
guys that'll give us x and since c is
invertible we also saw
we also saw that if we have
if we have just the standard
format for x or the standard coordinates
for x we can multiply that by c inverse
and then that will get us
that'll get us the coordinates for x
the coordinates for x with respect to b
with with respect to the basis b and
these two things you know if you just
multiply both sides of this equation
both sides let me do a different color
if you just multiply both sides of this
equation
by c inverse on the left hand side
you're going to get this equation right
there
now given that let's see if we can find
some type of relation now we know or
we're saying let's see what d times x b
is equal to
so let's say we if we take d times x b
so this thing right here should be equal
to d times
d
times d times
the representation or the coordinates of
x with respect to the basis b that's
what we're claiming we're saying that
this guy is equal to d times the
representation of x with respect to the
coordinates with respect to the basis b
right so let me write all of this down
let's scroll down i'll do it right here
because i think it's nice to have this
graphic up here
so we can say we can say that d
times
x
b
is equal to
it's equal to this thing right here it's
the same thing as the transformation of
x represented in coordinates with
respect to b or in these non-standard
coordinates so it's equal to
the transformation of x
represented in this coordinate system
represented with resp in coordinates
with respect to b
we see that right there but what is the
transformation of x
what is the transformation of x well
that's the same thing as a times x right
that's kind of the standard the standard
transformation if we had standard if we
x was represented in standard
coordinates so this is equal to
x in standard coordinates times the
matrix a
and then that will get us to this dot
and standard coordinates but then we
want to convert it to this non-standard
coordinates
just like that
now if we have this
if we have this how can we just get how
can we just figure out what the vector
ax should look like what this vector
should look like
well we can look at this equation right
here we have this
we have this this is the same thing as
this and so if we apply if we apply or
actually know we're going to go the
other way we have
we have this
we have that right there that's this
right there and we want to get just this
dot represented in regular standard
coordinates so what do we do we multiply
it by c
so let me write it this way
let me write if we multiply both sides
of this equation times c what do we get
we get
we get this right here
actually no i was looking at the right
equation the first time we have this
right here which is the same let me
first intuition is always right we have
this which is the same thing as this
right here
so this can be re rewritten this thing
can be rewritten as
c inverse
c inverse we don't have an x here we
have an ax here so c inverse
times a
x
right the vector ax represented in this
non-standard coordinates is the same
thing as multiplying the inverse of our
change of basis matrix times the vector
ax this will essentially if i have my
vector ax and i multiply it times the
inverse of the change of basis matrix i
will then have a representation of the
vector ax in my non-standard basis
now what is the vector x equal to
what is the vector x equal to well the
vector x
is equal to
our change of basis matrix times x
represented in these non-standard
coordinates so this is going to be equal
to
c inverse a
times x
x is just the same thing as
c
x is just c times
c times our non-standard coordinates
4x just like that so what is the the let
me summarize it just because i waffled a
little bit on this point right there
just because i got a little bit confused
if i start off with the non-standard
representation of x or x in coordinates
with respect to b i multiply them times
d
so if i start with this i multiply them
times d i get to that point right there
so this right there is the same thing as
this point right there
that point right there should be the
non-standard trans this non-standard
representation of the transformation of
x the non-standard representation or the
coordinates of the transformation of x
with respect to b
now the
the the transformation of x if x is in
standard coordinates is just a times x
so this is just a times x but i want to
represent it in these non-standard
coordinates now a times x in
non-standard coordinates
a times x in non-standard coordinates is
the same thing as c inverse times a
times x
right if you think this
is the same thing as this and so if you
have this and you want to represent a
non-standard coordinates you multiply it
by c inverse so then you'll get that
representation in non-standard
coordinates and then finally we say look
x
x is the same thing as c times the
non-standard coordinate representation
of x so x we can replace we can replace
x with that right there
and so the big takeaway here
the big takeaway here is that
d times
the coordinates of x with respect to the
basis b is equal to
c inverse
a times c
times the coordinates of x
times the coordinates of x with respect
to the basis b
and just like that we have a version so
d
must be equal to c inverse
a c so the the
if d is
the transformation
transformation
matrix
for
t
with respect
to the basis
to the basis b
b
and
and let me write here and
c
is the
change
the change
of basis
change of basis matrix
4b
then and let's one we know a is the let
me write that down and
might as well this is our big takeaway
and a
is the
transformation i'll write in shorthand
transformation matrix
matrix
for
t
with
respect
with respect
to the standard basis the standard
basis
then we can say
this is the big takeaway that d
our matrix d is equal to c inverse c
inverse times a
times c
that's our big takeaway from this video
which is really interesting i don't want
you to lose this point we now understand
that a is just for a certain set of
coordinates but there's a arbitrary
different bases that we can use to
represent rn so we can have different
matrices that represent the linear
transformation under different
coordinate systems
and if we want to figure out those
different matrices for a different
coordinate systems we can essentially
just construct construct the change of
basis matrix for the for the coordinate
system we care about and then generate
our new transformation matrix with
respect to the new basis by just
applying this result